- Ah, kids these days.
Ruining words for everybody.
Right now there's a very
popular meme going around
the internet "Netflix and Chill".
What does that even mean?
Is it a verb?
Is it a noun?
Whatever happened to just
asking someone out to dinner?
I'm going around today to ask my coworkers
if they in fact know what it
means to "Netflix and Chill".
Let's go find out.
Someone were to text you and ask you
if you wanted to watch Netflix and Chill,
what do they mean?
- To Netflix and Chill?
- Oh you wanna hang out.
- He wants to have sex.
- They would like to
watch Netflix and chill.
(sighs)
- Netflix and what?
- Chill.
- And chill, um.
- Is this like a sexual thing
that I don't understand?
- So there's a popular
meme going around right now
on the internet where Netflix and Chill
actually means someone's inviting you over
to have sexual relations with them.
- He's a a (censor beep) boy, stay away.
- So you're basically tricking her
into like coming over.
That's what this is?
- I always ask my friends to come over
and watch Netflix and chill.
- There's a side verse, like
"cool, I just wanna hang out
"and watch Netflix".
But it's like Netflix and chill just means
"Hey, Ty will you come over to my place,
make some ramen and just like, hook up."
- It's essentially like, hey
do you wanna relax together.
It's the best, it works,
it works most of the time.
- If you were going to Netflix
and Chill with someone,
what movie would you watch?
- Like, wait, am I actually
watching the movie, or?
- Something with lots of sexual tension.
So I could just like put that context
probably onto the person.
- I'm thinking Clueless.
- King of the Hill used to
be on Netflix. (laughing)
- Well I guess a movie that
you wouldn't wanna watch.
You're not gonna be watching it anyway.
- Probably Josie and the Pussycats.
- I'd be watching Frasier.
Not a movie, I'd be watching Frasier.
- So what did we learn here today?
Mmm, well, I'm still
a little bit confused.
Does it really mean to just
hang out and watch a movie
or does it mean I'm getting laid tonight?
It can mean different
things to different people.
Comment below on what
you think it really means
to Netflix and Chill.
Until next time.
- The first times I like hooked
up with a girl really heavy,
we were watching the movie Seven.